even though we witnessed Luffy's devil
fruit Awakening and his epic gear 5 form
there is still a lot that we don't
understand about the Nika devil fruit
how is it possible that it has a will of
its own and that it has been actively
avoiding capture by the world government
for eight centuries what is Luffy's
actual connection to the historical Joy
boy and why does zunesha proclaim that
joyboy himself has returned when Luffy's
devil fruit awakens how is all of this
connected to the dark origin of devil
fruits and to the void Century Oda has
already been foreshadowing the true
answer to these Mysteries but most
people just haven't noticed yet don't
believe me watch this video Until the
End you won't be disappointed if you
enjoy my one piece videos and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps me out with
that YouTube algorithm and we are trying
to awaken the full power of this channel
by hitting 2 million subscribers if you
haven't subscribed yet do me a huge
favor and subscribe right now every
single subscription counts it helps us
out a lot and we really want to hit that
mythical Zone status here on the channel
finally this video will contain some One
Piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in
chapter 1090 of the One Piece manga we
get a major reveal about the lineage
factor and how sharing the same lineage
factor affects someone's personality and
emotion when Frankie thanks the seraphim
s snake for undoing her petrification on
the straw hats Dr vegapunk is confused
because he doesn't remember programming
s snake to act that way nothing in her
programming or her General behavioral
patterns indicates that she would have
helped the straw hats in that situation
but we then get a flashback in which
Luffy is standing up close to a snake
and looking her right in the eyes he
calls her Hancock and he asks her to
please undo her powers on his comrades
he says please you're the only one who
can save them and surprisingly a snake
just gives in the flashback makes it
clear that s snake has a huge crush on
Luffy just like the original Boa Hancock
and of course we know that s snake was
created from boa's lineage factor which
is why she has access to bola's devil
fruit powers in the first place but the
idea that she has the same emotions as
boa is new jinbei laughs and says that s
snake is such a perfect copy of Hancock
that she seems to look down on literally
everyone except for Luffy just like the
original boa Vega Punk finds all of this
to be extremely interesting and he
begins taking notes it seems that even
he himself did not realize that emotions
are among the pieces of information that
are transferred between the lineage
Factor during the cloning process this
might seem just like a minor detail at
first especially with everything that's
happening on Egghead Island at the time
but this is actually a critical piece of
information that explains the true
nature of devil fruits and the true
connection between Luffy Nika and the
historical Joy boy from the void Century
once Luffy awakened the true nature of
his devil fruit and the gomogomunomi was
actually she revealed to be the
hitohitonomi model Nika a lot of people
kind of just forgot about the whole Joy
boy thing or at least they pushed it to
the back of their minds it seems that
most people assumed that Joy boy
promising that he would one day return
and zunesha proclaiming that Joy boy has
returned just means that someone else
has awakened the Nika devil fruit which
once belonged to the original Joy boy
from 800 years ago before we learned the
truth about the Nika fruit there were a
lot of theories about Luffy potachi
being The Reincarnation of Joy boy or
about Luffy potentially inheriting the
will of Joy boy or something along those
lines but after the real nature of
roofie's devil fruit was revealed it was
kind of just taken for granted that the
only thing that Luffy and the historical
Joy boy really have in common is that
they were both users of the same devil
fruit and they were both able to
eventually awaken it however the more we
learn about the lineage factor and how
this one-piece version of DNA connects
to the nature and origins of devil
fruits the more I think that the
relationship between Luffy Joy boy and
Nika is actually more complicated than
we realize we already know that all life
forms in the world of One Piece possess
a lineage factor and if you manipulate
someone's lineage factor from a young
age the growth of that life form can be
altered we also know consuming a devil
fruit literally Alters a person's
lineage factor which is what allows them
to gain new Supernatural powers that
seem to violate the laws of physics in
the past the lineage factors of animals
and existing devil fruit users have been
used to create artificial Zone devil
fruits known as the smile fruits
vegapunk was also able to synthesize
green blood with the lineage factors of
existing devil fruit users in order to
give the seraphim paramecia type devil
fruits which is why a snake has access
to the same devil fruit power as the
real Boa Hancock finally we have
evidence that the lineage Factor plays
an important role in the transference of
logia devil fruits as well for example
once Sabo consumes Aces former devil
fruit the metamera Nomi order repair
really hints at the fact that Sabo
inherited more than just as power there
seems to be some part of asa's
Personality still within the devil fruit
which is why sabo's actions and
mannerisms suddenly become more similar
to Aces after he consumes the fruit this
is oddly similar to the situation with s
snake where she seems to have inherited
not only boa's Powers but also her
personality and emotions including her
feelings of love for Luffy we are not
sure when exactly boa's lineage Factor
was extracted for the purposes of
creating a snake but it has to have been
after she gained her devil fruit power
the fact that the devil fruit power was
successfully transferred to as snake
through the lineage factor is the key
thing here either boa's lineage Factor
was taken from her a long time ago
before she even met Luffy which would
mean that she is literally genetically
predisposed to fall in love with him or
her lineage Factor was somehow taken
more recently after she met Luffy and
her existing love for him just like
carried over to a snake through the
lineage Factor now even though the Sabo
and a situation is different from the S
snake and boa situation one is just
someone consuming the same devil fruit
as a previous user and the other is a
complex cloning process that doesn't
involve the transfer of the devil fruit
itself there is a common denominator in
both situations and that common
denominator is the lineage Factor the
lineage factor is such an important
Concept in the world of One Piece it is
literally the blueprint of all life and
it is crucial for everything from devil
fruit powers and the cloning process to
turning people into superhuman weapons
as Vince monk judge was able to do by
manipulating the lineage factor of his
own children I mentioned earlier that
when someone consumes a devil fruit
their lineage factor is altered by the
devil fruit in question allowing them to
use superhuman powers that they weren't
able to use before but I believe that
when someone eats a devil fruit it's not
just their lineage factor that is
altered by the devil fruit the lineage
factor of that devil fruit user also
Alters the devil fruit it's self and the
user's own lineage Factor becomes
imprinted upon the devil fruit when the
user of Adele fruit dies and the devil
fruit is reincarnated some part of the
former user remains within the fruit in
the form of the former users lineage
factor that is what happened with Ace
when Sabo consumed the reincarnated Mira
Mera Nomi he also consumed some of Ace's
lineage Factor some of his DNA and when
the devil fruit altered sabo's own
lineage Factor it combined it with some
of Aces linear Factor this is why sabo's
Behavior suddenly becomes more similar
to Aces it is kind of like that real
world medical phenomenon that leads
organ transplant recipients to suddenly
begin exhibiting some personality traits
of the organ's original owner now if my
theory is correct and the lineage
factors of former users are actually
imprinted upon a devil fruit and then
passed on to the next user of that same
devil fruit this would explain so much
about devil fruits in general and also
also about Luffy's true connection to
Joy boy why do devil fruits appear to
have a will of their own their will
comes from the lineage factor of former
users the Nika fruit in particular seem
to have such a powerful will that it was
actively avoiding capture by the world
government for like 800 years and that
is because its former user was joyboy
the greatest enemy of the world
government and his Relentless
determination to free the world was
carried over in the dika devil fruit
after his death why did Sabo inherit
some of Asus personality traits when
Sabo consumed Asus former devil fruit he
also consumed some of Ace's linear
tractor why did a snake instantly
develop a crush on Luffy and was willing
to go against her own programming in
order to make him happy it is because
the same cloning process that gave her
the ability to use boa's devil fruit
also gave her boa's personality traits
and emotions through boa's lineage
Factor so what does this mean for Luffy
it means that Luffy didn't just consume
the historical joyboy's former devil
fruit he also consumed some of joyboy's
lineage Factor through that devil fruit
this lineage Factor contains some of
joyboy's personality traits and Luffy
inherited them just like Sabo inherited
some of Ace's personality traits this
means that some part of the original Joy
boy really is alive again inside of
Luffy so in a way the original Joy boy
really has returned joyboy knew about
the fact that his lineage Factor would
be imprinted upon the Nika devil fruit
after his death and that is why he
promised that he would one day return to
fulfill his promise and he really meant
it when zunesha proclaimed that joyboy
had returned he wasn't just being
dramatic he could really sense joyboy's
lineage Factor inside of Luffy in the
past I made videos talking about how the
original Joy boy may have been a
lunarian and I argued that Luffy
inherited some of joyboy's lunarian DNA
through his lineage Factor which was
passed down to Luffy within the Nika
devil fruit this explains why Luffy has
always had a seemingly superhuman
tolerance to heat and Flames why he was
able to use Firebase powers like red
hawk and Red Rock and why his hair turns
white when he goes into gear 5. these
could all be hints that Luffy inherited
joyboy's lunarian lineage factor and of
course Joy boy being lunarian would also
explain why the world government has
been so obsessed with hunting down and
destroying the purlinarians ever since
the void Century but I won't get into
the details of the lunarian theory here
because while the lunarian theory is
plausible joyboy being a lunarian is not
a requirement for the lineage Factor
Theory as a whole to be true to sum it
all up I think that Oda has been hinting
for a long time that while a devil fruit
definitely Alters the lineage factor of
its user this is not the only genetic
change that occurs when someone consumes
a devil fruit some of the user's lineage
factor is also imprinted upon that devil
fruit and when the user dies and the
devil fruit is reincarnated and then
consumed by the next user the next user
will also be consuming some of the
previous users lineage Factor along with
the devil fruit so when Luffy consumed
the Nika devil fruit he didn't just
consume one of the strongest devil
fruits in existence he also consumed the
lineage factor of one of the strongest
Warriors in history and the world
government's most powerful and most
notorious enemy Joy boy Luffy is not
only the user of the same devil fruit as
joyboy but on a genetic level he really
is Joy boy at least to an extent because
of that when Luffy consumed the Nika
devil fruit and when it finally awakened
to its true power the original Joy boy
really did return in a way I wonder if
Sun God Nika the one who gave the devil
fruit its very name was a real person
once just like Joy boy I mean maybe Nika
is just a legend that came from the
devil fruit itself or maybe the original
Joy boy inherited the Lenny each factor
of an even older Godly Warrior Legend
and this is what allowed him to become
such a fierce Warrior during the void
century and now of course Luffy is on
his way to becoming The Greatest Warrior
of this era with the help of the Nika
devil fruit and the lineage factor of
its former legendary users let me know
what you guys think do devil fruits
contain the lineage factors of its
former users and are these lineage
factors transferred from one user to
another through the devil fruit itself
does Luffy possess the lineage Factor
the DNA of the original Joy boy from 800
years ago could this secret connection
to Joy boy help explain Luffy's
incredible willpower determination and
commitment to Freedom definitely leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
I can't wait to hear all your crazy Nika
Joy boy theories since we've been
talking about Luffy's devil fruit
Awakening and gear 5 so much don't miss
our full-length video talks about all
the crazy powers and abilities of Nika
and gear 5. check it out right now Link
in the description and on screen if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
right now and if you want to help us
awaken the true power of this Channel
and hit 2 million subscribers subscribe
right now every single subscription
counts and it helps us out a lot